it's our family let's get into it
i'll take the next one okay so next up
for all you daters out there we've got a
story about how online dating is
evolving the verge reports that a dating
app hinge is adding a new audio feature
that allows users to add voice
recordings to their profiles it's meant
to give just a little bit more data on
who you might be dating
now you can sing a little song you can
share your best impression you can give
a fun fact actually we have one check it
out
a random fact that i love is that when
elephants look at humans it's the same
way we look at dogs so they think we're
cute
and that's
just really funny to think about
all right okay so so what do we think do
we think this is helpful do you like
this voice memos look i'm all in favor
of this
i like it
because the the point of online dating
is to make things a little more
efficient you're not waiting around for
your aunt to fix you up with somebody
you're going through you know you're
computerizing this thing that is an
extra computer data point to help you
weed out the yeses and the nodes okay i
like it i like it i think you can tell a
lot sometimes by a person's voice
but their vocabulary how they speak in
that case his sense of humor i like it a
lot i
love that you do yeah i do because i am
a personality first looks second
and when you're on look second
okay you don't like that okay well i'm
not saying i'm not saying looks should
be first but i do think they're
important exactly
listen you don't have to be an adonis
i'm not saying that but i don't want a
booger bear i want something
i want somebody that i'm at least
physically
physically attracted to so to me you
have to be physically attracted to them
and whatever that is now hold on you
want chemistry chemistry but chemistry
comes in the voice i think yes
i agree yeah andy warhol has a quote
that i really loved which is fall in
love with your eyes closed now i think
that's probably far too far for you and
i agree you have to be attracted there
has to be some chemistry but i have
fallen history yes in love with people
because you get to know them and it is
so hard on dating apps i feel like i'm
always swiping left because they're too
young i don't know who they are dating
apps swiping left i
you told me you said i'm not gonna do it
no i do i every once in a while and then
i like freak out and jump off if i could
do it and people wouldn't know it was me
i would do it wait why not knowing it
was you i don't i don't know i don't
know it just feels i don't know isn't
that getting off on a weird foot yeah i
know but i wish i was brave enough to do
it i do well i prefer you meet somebody
to a friend of a friend of a friend or
you meet somebody somewhere i don't know
but i believe that there's a lot of nice
single people out there and we're like
fish not fish ships passing through the
night just going past each other
you have to go out if you're single and
you don't want a date online you have to
go out by yourself you have to go sit at
a bar because if you're with a group of
people no one's going to approach you so
you're going out with insulated by
friends you won't go online gail it's
not going to happen
i'm sorry i can't even go i won't even i
went to a restaurant once by myself
and so i'm sitting there with my book
and the waiter comes up to me and says
excuse me ma'am your book is upside down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
excuse me ma'am your book is up i hope
you tipped him because that is a great
heads up yeah
yeah that is good oh
i did say thank you i did say i i i i
will have to talk about this online
what's the next topic
um well actually tony your story okay so
i mean this is related to the
assumptions that people make maybe when
they see your picture online uh okay the
question is does having a beard civil
war beard uh mean that you are
particularly good with a budget no
no i would say actually i'd say i have
keep reading keep reading
a new survey finds that a lot of
americans think the beard means you're
good with money fox business reports
that lending tree surveyed americans and
found that nearly half of them say yes
men in particular with facial hair we
got a close shot of our nate burleson
here yeah yeah
with finances nate agrees with this
right something about the beard
particularly a longer beard seems to
evoke like wisdom
and responsibility
basically sexist old-fashioned ideas
that i have no idea why they're showing
up in this survey yeah interesting i
found it funny though i was looking at
the women in the crowd and you could
tell they know dudes with beards that
are broke
that are broken
a couple of black bearded men
one girl was like
in that survey
do you think i should try a beard you
guys yeah well so a beard actually i
think would say the the most interesting
thing in this whole survey actually is
that uh it's not that about half of
people think beards mean you're good
with money it's that most bearded people
think they're good with money so like
having the beard makes you think you
know what you're doing so grow it if
you're confident ross i think this
survey although it comes from lending
tree which is a trusted source
it's a little hello
[Music]